when it comes to gaming whether it's
action rpg or simulation
staying in the action means being online
but in the offline world
you rep your fandom with merch will
critter junction's e-commerce shop be
able to handle their hype
stay tuned to find out
[Music]
without any in-person conventions this
year critter junction players from
around the world have begun to flood
their site to purchase character cards
apparel and other swag critter junction
has been testing app engine standard to
run their new merchandise shop
because app engine auto scales their
application across multiple instances to
meet the demands of additional traffic
but during load testing they used cloud
trace to measure response latency
and they noticed a higher than usual
latency when they used heavier
concurrent requests
to their services http endpoint
you see pending latency is how long a
request can be sitting in the queue
before app engine decides to spin up
another instance
if all of your app instances are busy
when a request arrives
the request will wait in a queue to be
handled by the next available instance
as the load increases
this means requests are processed more
slowly
app engine will then start a new
instance to help based on limits you set
like cpu
utilization throughput and max
concurrent requests of the current
running instances
but what they didn't know is that app
engine also needs to load their app's
code into a fresh
instance when they redeploy a new
version of their app
and when maintenance and repairs of
underlying infrastructure or
physical hardware occur though cold
starts on app engine are rare
the first request or loading request
sent to a new instance can take
longer to be processed because the
instance first has to load your app's
code
including any libraries and resources
needed to handle the request
this means a gradual increase in
response times to handle new traffic
what you want instead is to get the
initialization to happen
sooner before a new instance serves live
traffic
you can do this by using a warm-up
request which loads application code
into an instance ahead of time
before any live requests reach it app
engine attempts to detect when your app
needs a new
instance and initiates a warm-up request
to initialize it
any new instances accept requests after
they finish loading your app's code
new requests can then be handled faster
warm-up requests are used by the app
engine scheduler which controls
auto-scaling of instances based on your
configuration
app engine issues get requests to ah
warm up
and then you can implement handlers for
this request
in your code to perform application
specific tasks
like pre-caching app data for most
supported languages
just add the warm-up element under the
inbound services directive
in your app.yaml file then create a
handler that will process
requests that are sent to ah.warmup your
handler should perform
any warm-up logic that is needed by your
app
let's walk through a go example our
function performs the required setup
steps for the application to function
and it logs when an app engine warm-up
request is used to create the new
instance
these warm-up steps happen in setup for
consistency with cold start
instances everything else remains the
same
this setup function executes the
per-instance one-time warm-up
and initialization actions finally
the index handler responds to requests
with our greeting
one thing to note is warm-up requests
don't work in all cases
despite the best effort attempt to send
requests to already warmed up instances
when enabled so you might still face
loading requests like if the instance is
the first one being started up
or if there's a steep ramp up in traffic
in these cases
you should use the resident instances
which you can learn about below
once warm-up requests were implemented
critter junction was able to reduce cold
start instances during increases in
traffic to their online shop once
convention season was underway
stickers for everyone check out the link
below for language specific steps on
warm-up requests and stay tuned for
what's next for critter junction
and remember always be architecting
you